you know i'm
notorious for my love of gray characters
and one of the greatest characters in
the entire westeros is damon targaryen
the rogue prince
uh we we took one of the sidebars and
made a separate story out of it the
rogue prince
damon is the younger brother of king
viserys the first
for a time he was the heir to the throne
when viserys had no children
and then vasara started having children
and he stopped being the heir to the
throne he's a notorious
bad boy a rogue in every sense of the
word
he was a rival for viceroy's
sister and his own niece renera and then
later he became the husband of her nera
he switches sides several times you
never know what side he's going to come
down on
he's a very colorful and unpredictable
character
and i think he has to rank up there as
my favorite
when ravens carried the news of aegon's
coronation to dragonstone
princess rhaenyra summoned her own black
council
with her was her uncle and husband damon
targaryen considered by many to be the
most dangerous man in westeros
arrax was struggling to stay aloft in
the gale
when a roar shook the very foundations
of storm's end
eamonn rose through the clouds and below
him
the monstrous veigar veigar was
five times the size of arax and the
hardened survivor of a hundred battles
vegar caught him above shipbreaker bay
watchers on the castle wall
saw distant blasts of flame and heard a
shriek drown out the thunder
prince lucas fell broken to be swallowed
by the waves
with his death the war of ravens came to
an end
and the war of fire and blood began
[Music]
heard of her son's death she collapsed
she considered ending the war right then
until a raven arrived from her husband
damon
her son would be avenged
whispers slithered through the taverns
and back alleys of flea bottom
two men were found one was a former gold
cloak
the other a rat catcher in the red keep
who knew all his secrets
history remembers them only as blood and
cheese
one night queen helena entered the royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed
without warning blood and cheese
bursting
daggers in hand they told her that a
debt was owed
a son for a son rhaenyra's forces struck
yet another blow
the moment the lord of harrenhal saw
damon targaryen circling the castle on
his dragon correxes
he struck his banners and surrendered
the blacks now had the strongest castle
in the riverlands
after rook's rest aim and one eye took
command of the greens from his crippled
and poppy adult brother
eamonn was the blood of the dragon and
dragons don't cower behind city walls
he marched the king's army north to take
back harrenhal from rhaenyra's husband
damon but when he and kristen cole
reached the castle
they found the gates open with damon and
all his men
gone that night they feasted their
victory
damon had fled rather than face their
wrath
the damon was more snake than dragon as
eamonn marched
north he'd flown keraxis south
slithering past the green army over the
waters of the god's eye
one day king's landing looked up and saw
two dragons circling their foul
city damon and rhaenyra had come for her
throne
for the city was defenseless eamonn had
taken the king's army from the city
and worse he'd taken his dragon vaga
seeing that resistance was hopeless the
small council surrendered the city the
queen mother alicent
and the broken queen helena but not
king aegon somehow despite his wounds
and delirium
he had vanished from the city
when a new army of green loyalists
marched up from the reach
and laid siege to the city of tumbleton
rhaenyra sent two of her dragon siege to
lay waste to them
instead the dragon seeds proved their
bastard nature
and betrayed her they burned the city
and all the black forces garrisoned
within
lucky for her they didn't turn towards
king's landing but hauled and drank in
the ruins with the greens
who were victorious and somewhat
confused
rainier now mistrusted all the dragon
seeds
including the girl who rode with her
husband damon hunting eamonn in the
riverlands
she ordered the girl's head be sent to
her
but there was a complication
as well as her dragon the girl had taken
to riding daemon
when damon received the queen's order he
proclaimed the queen's words and work
he sent the girl away at dawn watching
her and her dragon vanish into the
morning mists
then damon sent the challenge to his
nephew aymond and flew to heron hall
alone to wait
fourteen days later a shadow blacker
than any passing cloud swept over
harrenhal
veigar had come at last and on her back
rode
one-eyed prince eamonn he mocked damon
for facing him alone
you have lived too long uncle and damon
replied
on that much we agree then the old
prince
climbs stiffly onto the back of his
dragon caraxes
but neglected to fasten the chains that
secured ryder to sun
the sun was close to setting when as one
the two dragons leapt
into the sky daemon took her axes up
swiftly until they disappeared into a
bank of clouds
vegard older and slower ascended more
gradually
up and up vegar sword searching for
karazhi's
sudden as a thunderbolt a shrieking
karaxi's dove upon vegard
locked together the dragon stumbled
toward the lake
karaxi's jaws closed about veigar's neck
but vega raked open karaxi's belly and
her teeth
ripped off a wing the lake rushed up
with terrible speed
then damon targaryen who had never
fastened his riding chains
stood in his saddle he leapt from his
dragon to aemons
and in his hand was dark sister the
valyrian sword of aegon's sister queen
visenya
as eamonn's one eye looked up in terror
daemon ripped off his nephew's helm
and drove the sword down into his one
remaining eye
so hard the point came out the back of
the young
prince's throat half a heartbeat later
the dragons struck the lake sending up a
gout of water so high
that it was said to have been as tall as
harrenhal's great
tower the lake boiled with dragon blood
and then was still daemon targaryen was
9 and 40 at his
death prince eamond had only turned 20.
vegar the greatest of the targaryen
dragons
had counted 181 years
thus passed the last living creature
from the days of aegon's conquest
back in king's landing queen rhaenyra
didn't have much time to grieve for her
stupid husband
the mad former queen helena flung
herself from a balcony to be impaled
upon the iron spikes lining the moat of
maegor's holdfast
you